[Music]
good morning gamers
it's your favorite v tuber
god damn this what is happening i got my
glasses on
[Music]
oh god let's play some minecraft
i become a female for like a split
second when i put on my glasses
there we go yeah oh this is
weird all right gamers for those of you
who didn't watch the live stream
important update we have a new friend
two new friends this is bonky he's a
mule
he had sex with jurgen no wait no no no
no no no no no
this is donkey he had uh time with
jargon
and they made bonky that's right uh
you're gonna
add i mean donkey's stuck in a minecart
i don't even know how this is possible
no careful careful no no no no
no stop this no i need you donkey i need
your donkey i've been through this once
before
come back no no no no no no no please
please please i need him i need him i
need him
he'll be fine he'll be fine ah
donkey don't scare me like that he's
actually
really really useful i didn't realize
this there you go
okay uh because you can put chest on
them
i had no idea wait so if i ride him how
do i ride him without killing him there
we go
uh yeah i can use extra inventory which
is actually
super good uh because i've been farming
santa can i get you out of there buddy
okay uh i'm just gonna try and hit
eat hey dimitri
stay out of this all right maybe
fishing run it works on bedrock you can
fish people out of stuff i wish
oh my god
let me just use my hands
alright well you live there now i was
actually looking forward to using you
but
i guess i'll use your child you live in
this minecart do you understand me
you will never die but you will have to
stay here
oh that's good get a friend
i like that i like that that's cute
oh my gosh dude can you put a chest on a
mule
let me try that that'd be useful then i
can put one on
uh bonkey then i need a saddle don't i
maybe i can remove your saddle is that
okay
sorry but uh sorry donkey you look cute
without the saddle
oh i forgot there's another edition of
evil
let's discuss that one you may remember
these magma blocks
um have i tamed you oh you
what a sound dude come on bonky
oh my god blanky what is it
what is that sound that is not a sound
dude i gave you so much please let me
write you
what is a
hell is up with you there we go let me
love you
oh i think we got him nice sweet look at
you
funky all right can i put the chest this
is a pivotal moment
yes sweet nice
nice nice all right here
she is water sheep reincarnated as a cat
i swear to you this piece of
i don't like you i i put a magma block
can you guys not be so goddamn loud holy
crap dude
you're so annoying i'm killing you just
so you're quiet
all right anyway i hate her i hate the
cat
super annoying don't like her not one
bit uh let's get your leash let's go
bonky
oh wow you're really bad at stairs dude
oh thanks thanks ponky almost died
oh they love each other
so i got some better equipment
which is pretty cool i got a efficiency
five
and that's almost got four but on a
shovel i never had that before i think
at least
and it's god damn beautiful i think i
discovered the fastest way to level up
for me right now and i'll show you in
one sec what i mean
i have this ready for my new sword once
i'm level 30
which i am is there does it need
anything else i'm breaking looting yeah
i need sharpness that's what i'm waiting
for
oh excuse me good night good night
donkey
all right so let's head out oh my god
i'm going to die we're going to head out
sorry
you've been replaced by bonky
oh yeah i don't know why i put that
there oh my god that's slow
okay bonky watch watch this dude
like seriously watch that hold up
holy crap dude it took me
so long to get all the sand before
and now it's just like oh i need sand
i get it faster than i can pick it up
it's insane dude so yeah basically i'm
i'm trying to get
better gear i'm happy with the helmet
i'm happy with the boots
i just need better of this because these
boots saved my life
less the stream a creeper creeped up on
me and blew up but since i had blast
protection
your boy made it out alive it would have
been a tragic ending wouldn't it
bonky i wouldn't have met you bunkie
that would have been sad
i got people to live for now i got
people that depend on me
i can't just oh my god this i cannot get
over the shovel
it's so good this would have taken me
like 10 minutes to get
i'm a goddamn machine baby
i also really need really desperately
need to start making potions
i don't have any nether warts i think i
need to go back
to the nether castle today and see if i
can find them but i
i'm pretty sure that they didn't spawn
in that nether castle
is there any other way to get nether
warts with great power comes great
efficiency
look at this so now i can just dump all
of it on bunkie
and i can keep going amazing it's not
even going to be a desert while we're
done with this it's ridiculous i can't
get over it it's just so crazy
i played so much minecraft but i never
used good gear
no one cares about preserving a desert
right everyone's like oh we need to
bring
preserve the rain forest yeah what about
the deserts huh
this is what's happening to the deserts
everywhere right now
right bonky bunky don't go there you
want to go there mommy
i watched a bunch of compilations of
people dying in hardcore because i
wanted to understand what most people
die from
and a lot of them is choking from sand
which is no oh my god
you see what i mean it's not gonna
happen to me
whoa whoa you see that that is not gonna
should we explore bunkie
oh chainmail
i need a i need a better
this is a really bad idea i should not
have jumped down there oh i'm an idiot
that could have been bad jesus never
jump
down in caves i've also learned that
from watching people die in hardcore i
think you know which one
all right can you jump over i don't
think he can oh
he can nice sweet are you doing the me3
[Music]
cool we're gonna melt the guard church
like
there is none just watch gamers
this is gonna lit up our church of coal
has never looked so beautiful
yes my god more
give me more oh oh yeah we got bonkies
let's not forget bonky's stack where the
heck did he go dmitry
where is he oh my gosh
thank you how you doing yeah
that's great that's fantastic remember
when i said
five furnitures y'all never thought i'd
get used out of this
you were wrong if you don't have a house
of furnaces you're clearly not an
efficient minecraft gamer
oh it's gonna look so good in the night
oh it sounds so
satisfying why is this making me
genuinely smile
one day this whole thing is gonna glow
that is
beautiful man oh god look at it
in all its glory oh
oh my god yes
yes yes all right i'm going to bed
hopefully my house doesn't burn down
good night donkey
so the reason why i'm melting glass is
to trade glass with these guys because
they pay a lot
and so i can get i want protection
is that yours hey you want to learn a
new job
does this not belong to anyone it
belongs to you blast protection
oh i have that why did i buy that i
don't need that what is this
that's yours okay i hate when that
happens
i realize if that glitch is out you just
have to open a chest and bam it's gone
i mean it's back okay so i want either
lure
sharpness or protection
and i'm not getting either this is great
come on
come on pick the right job luck of the
sea
i would pick it but i need the other
ones more desperately
i need that protection power would have
been good but i'm more desperate for
other things
i'm sure later on when i want to try and
get power i'll curse myself or not
so touch would have been good and i'm
sure i curse myself later
when i need it this is how it goes you
know
so i was thinking should i have a
different type of
gear when i'm in the nether that is just
fire protection focused i thought it
made more sense to just have the potion
ready if i go in the nether
but the problem is i have nothing i
can't make any potions
yes
yes that is nice i am already
rich as hell dude um all right give me
which one was that you sweet
let's go gamers i'm gonna get myself a
new sword
this feels very nerdy this playthrough
it's very different
i have more knowledge i have more
understanding look at he's still going
how many levels does it cost if i do
this 12
or 22 okay so this is gonna cost me 12
no matter what
oh god that's awful uh five
what's the best way to do this i assume
i do this
no no oh i messed up
oh god i messed up
oh no what have i done i should not have
ah
oh no 35. well
it will be a badass sword once it's done
and i'll never have to worry about
making a sword again
but yeah that's that's a lot
actually we will level up that really
fast trust me
let me get some of this glass and i'll
show you what i mean see how fast i'm
leveling up right now
whoa whoa do you see that you i bet you
can't even keep oh
21 you can't even keep up i won't grab
all of it i'll describe some
so now we turn this into glass panels
and these guys just love glass panels
[Music]
it's their favorite thing hey look at
that already level 25.
nice okay cool i have it okay
so i think my setup will be one of them
two of them have protection
the helmet and the chest and then this
will have fire and this will have
glass i think that's the best combo
y'all y'all tell me if you know
something i don't know but apparently
they don't stack
so having all five protection means that
they go a little less the more you have
of it
that's as far as i understand i actually
went in to creative just to kind of test
out on this server
let's see what i have look i have fire
protection i need to know this stuff
i i i only get one chance
i can just chill and lava huh oh it's
because i had the potion
that's why uh let's get some milk
it's still very little but i'll still
take damage if i fall in lava
even with this much fire protection so
that's a bummer
so i think potion is the way to go we're
gonna have to do something i
really don't want to do which is go back
to the nether castle
oh i forgot this is uh queen of the
underworld
um alabama
she escaped into the nether i think i
think she's also reincarnated
sometimes they spawn down here all right
not excited about this one bit i also
need
magma cream if i'm gonna have to
actually use the enchantments
come at me bro uh see i shouldn't even
jump there he could knock me out
ah hardcore is stressful man i am so
invested in this series i don't wanna
die that's what a coward would say
yeah one day i hope i'm comfortable
enough to do a face reveal you know
oh there's two of them uh it's a baby
cool let's kill the mother let's send
the message
nice clean
oh no your mommy die die oh
this is i i feel so bad for you
i'll get you one day oh time to put on
paints
time to put on my gucci pants hey guys
i'm wearing gucci just like you guys
we're cool right oh this is great
oh don't tempt me like that little child
oh don't tempt me like this oh okay good
for you
good for oh don't tempt me there's
nobody even lava down there
so yeah i'm pretty sure there's no
nether words but i want to check it out
just to be clear because i i i would
love some otherwise we're gonna have to
find another nether castle which kind of
sucks
but look it is kind of a crappy one
isn't it i wish i had a totem
of undying or something but here we go
so i think here is just where the
spawner is
hello
what's making that noise yeah there's
nothing here unless here perhaps
hello there sir i wish i had that sword
y'all don't want to play oh they give
magma cream excellent i didn't know that
i forgot about that
cool perfect i need something because
that's what we make the potions out of
sorry little children not the anakin
skywalker on you
is there a method of finding oh i don't
expect you guys
this is one right olaf i know how to way
to deal with these guys
oh too tall you're too tall
yeah i bet you weren't tall now huh
there's no god damn nether wars
god damn it i didn't know this was
possible to have another castle with no
nether words
i feel cheated you know look it's all
dead ends
dang it guys i wanted the nether nipples
oh they're kissing so cute
do i dare to mine this gold are you mad
at me
i think yes i should probably kill them
just to be safe
i'm sorry all right i'm sorry
well oh god the nether is so scary man
that's what a coward i guess i'm a
coward guys i
changed everything i ever said about
cowards all right
we're leveling up at least
oh lord okay let's uh
set up perimeters hey dude
yeah i'm playing it safe i don't care
for a second
this is a little dangerous i there you
are
oh sucks to be tall i know exactly how
that feels like
it's not fair is it it's so ironic
because i want to find another ward so
the nether can be more safe but to find
the netherwarts
i have to do unsafe things this is like
damn it
maybe i should try and head south oh
don't tease me
oh you're teasing me hey little child
hey are you lost oh no
no one saw it i'm going to hell guys
oh look at you they're striking from the
trees that's my strategy
two of them three of them why don't have
bow and arrow
are they gonna jump down get off my
bridge
okay sure oh my gosh if they fall down
uh oh oh
what is happening why are you here how
did you make it
you were supposed to die come back
come back here come back here
oh no oh god oh god
i don't want to do this
oh idiots are jumping down
stop jumping down it's not worth it
sorry i'm sorry
damn he makes me fly dude oh
i'm out i'm out i'm out okay
we're good we're back we're back safe i
don't like them
what up alabama i offer torches
please bless my journey ahead
thank you alabama no ulla no no no
alabama
no no get back
that's fine okay so i need to find
another
nether castle i need to make sure i can
actually see it
this is very laggy it's all right we
have alabama's blessing guys we can do
this oh
i don't like this the thing is i've run
this place
many times before but i am just really
scared
another castle where are you
this is awful how
how was i so ballsy i went
no i just realized
i forgot my shoelaces untied and i need
to go home
alabama you blessed me once again
you kept my journey safe and for that i
kiss you
thank you sweet home alabama
how to get netherworld it can only be
found in the nether
great how about this we start off by
getting our sword right
oh they're sleeping that's so cute don't
they know i don't allow sleeping in my
base
have you not refreshed are you serious
oh my gosh i forgot time doesn't travel
seriously all right we have one
reasonable fella
cats keep it there i'll let her live
i'll let her live guys you however
you stinkiest of all i hate you
don't try to meow your way out of this i
bet you're the reason why there's no
netherward
it's not fair man what do i oh look how
the light shines through my house that's
so cool
yes ah shower me with d
bro oh
i like the sound of that
nice level 30 baby oh my god the stoics
33 already nice that was fast maybe i
should make more babies
hey chiquita pop out another couple ones
for me yeah
there you go make babies
more babies what are you doing
nice i want a lot more babies you
understand me
i want a lot more servants
yes excellent let's go get my sword
how what up donkey you look good
oh my gosh this kind of hurts i never
ever
ever spent this much
i'm broke now but i have a fat sword
i could put knockback on it as well but
i i don't know
i'm broke
oh what are you doing don't have sex
with me what the hell
you two come on guys come on yes the
love is in the air
as soon as chiquita you let me down
so what am i missing now in terms of
enchantment i need a range weapon
if i'm gonna have to go in the nether
right maybe i should have kept the power
five
dang it what's the best one i have power
two
amazing and how many arrows one
amazing let's go try and find some
netherright
and another castle that's a that's a
good idea
it's a little stressful though i'm not
gonna lie it's stressful
alabama please bless my journey ahead
whoa holy crud nice
thank you i'm just mowing through this
hello nice
are there more of you
oh my god i'm so lucky looks like we're
in a different biome now maybe i should
go up
to the surface just to check it out
nope maybe i changed my mind
we could go up here that's exciting
nope let's not do that yeah we're out
gucci pants on another castle
come on uh
sometimes they do bead like that though
sometimes they do be like that
y'all tell me in the comments if you see
something i don't
i've already lost where i came from i
have a
fat sword now i really want to try it
they're scared of the mushroom aren't
they
let them burn hey man you've seen
another castle around here
uh they're scared of a little mushroom
no nether castle
bastion no nothing this is
amazing
what just happened what did i just
witness
how there's nowhere to jump from
what could there be warts is that no i
thought it was another right
is it worth going down there hey buddy
what do you think of that hey stop
you're supposed to not
coward
whoa all right it just got real
back off
that is really useful
two of ya
not so tough now are ya
i'll check it out there might be
something good right what's the worst
thing
that can happen let's place you there
we're playing it safe guys don't worry
that's what a coward
and i'm not really
really ah that is so incredibly garbage
is crying obsidian any good i think it's
for respawn points i think it's actually
completely useless
chain is kind of cool though
there we go is that no it isn't
is it are you serious is it really
oh oh oh god how do i get there
let me spawn there let's make sure we
can find our way back
we're doing this all right this could be
the end of
everything if i don't make it out alive
just know it's been a pleasure
and a privilege not the safest way to
enter
but i think it's the only way no way
i can go like this okay this works is
that it
whoa the answer is no
hello
luckily i do a shoot load of damage
what's up guys
what that is so lucky dude
holy crap spooky scary skeleton
i'm shivering down your spine please
have another ward
i'm gonna need these for the health
potions
this is a huge one that has to be in
other words here
i am completely lost this is such a
weird one
i look insane but it works i
it's just so hard to see
what get out of here cool we got four
that's sweet this is already a win
now i just gotta make it out alive
oh my gosh oh my gosh
oh my gosh i just have to find my way
back i don't know
the way what are you doing in here
oh god
okay
[Music]
i just want to go home i'll follow the
torches hey do you know
you know the way back man i want to go
home
is it here no
yes adios amigos
we did it i am so just going home now
yes so smart we got one
yeah oh my god i'm back home
sweet freaking home
alabama alabama all of them
[Music]
five kisses you blessed me on my journey
i thought i was a gunner there for a
minute
[Music]
oh it never felt so good to be home
i'll place you there you tried to kill
me didn't you
cat i'm on to you
i know what you're planning
oh my gosh i look insane dude
oh yeah oh donkey i never thought i'd
see your beautiful ash again
maybe i'll put it on my helmet because
it looks so cool yeah
helmet looks the coolest let's go with
that damn do
i look great i feel good
i'm ready nothing's gonna stop us gamers
thank you for watching another episode
of minecraft
brofist